racist for Life racist for life baby
keep it racist the places that tell you
that the world is racist are the only
places that you experiened the racism
which I think is so odd La
[Laughter]
[Music]
baby hey welcome everybody to an amazing
and very special episode of the careful
boys where today we have Mr Matt Kim in
the everyone to thank you thank you
thank you thank you thank you hey Matt
all right so all of our fans want to
know who the are you Matt waa that's
like the craziest question because I
don't think I'm anybody that's tight but
you're somebody like I'm not though like
I just decided one day I want to open up
my camera and start talking to it and
give what I perceive to be what's going
on in the world and it's not like I ever
planned on so many people listening to
me or watching me like there was no
agenda or objective to do that it just
kind of happened and this entire year
and this entire 6 months has been like
the wildest journey of my life like the
craziest Evol like an avalanche one
thing as in I mean when I started this
about less than a year ago I was like if
maybe in 2 years 10,000 people listen to
me like that would have been a huge W
right and then all of a sudden it's like
more and more and more and starts
snowballing wow when did you start I did
my first podcast episode about a year
ago oh wow I didn't start making my
Clips online which is kind of what I'm
known for I didn't start doing that
until May wow 2023 yeah and what what is
what are you talking about what is the
content that started snowballing and
started getting a lot of attention so
the very first video that I had to go
viral and the first video I made I made
a I did a story it was on Father's Day I
did a story
about it was a guy that shot a man and a
woman Asian man and a woman in a car in
Seattle oh I remember that was pregnant
M and I was talking about how the media
doesn't cover this and I ended with the
question how many people died that day
because a pregnant woman had died how
many people died it's a real question oh
are these the restaurant owners yes we
covered them here too and it that video
my first video I ever did talking to a
camera that did like 3 million views wow
and then ever since then it kind of went
and that really messed with people cuz
people were like well two people clearly
died cuz it was a mom and their unborn
child and the other side's like well
like abortion they're not actually it's
not actually a baby now you got this
really like cuz the story hits hard but
at the same time how do you qualify how
many people died and then they're like
well according to Seattle law like he
should have been charged with two
murders he should have been but they
charged him with one so he actually got
charged with murder for killing one
person and that story kind of really
messed people up and that's kind of what
started people watching
what what made you want to start even
sharing your perspective or point of
view on life I think I I was one of
those guys that was at home and always
yelling at the
TV like a old Dad yeah like the old guy
my my wife was pregnant my daughter look
at Dallas Cowboys get it
together it's Dallas Cowboys
huh started those guys it was just
yelling at the TV and my wife would say
like seriously go tell someone that
cares waa cuz my daughter was like so
young she was like a few months old
that's a good wife though and I'm
yelling at the TV and she's like you're
going to wake up the kid you got to tell
someone that cares that's and I remember
I had just started watching Andrew Tate
early in the year and Andrew Tate's
voice is like in the back of my head get
off your ass and do something you know
what I mean yeah yeah um do something
difficult be something different right
put yourself in uncomfortable situations
you think girls want to sleep with a
loser exactly yeah think they do I don't
I'm not a
loser well he has a wife wife and a
child no one's going to I'm never going
to get laid with this
[__] that's what it was I I went into
the office one day and I was like we're
going to start a podcast and the guys in
my office like what and I'm like yeah
like how do we do that I'm like I have
no idea I had never been on someone's
podcast before I had never tried to do a
podcast before like I had no experience
in any of it I just felt like this is
what I something I wanted to do what did
you do before that you could even say
that yeah what office were you Home
Depot we're going to start a podcast
what so I own a lighting company and in
the back I had like an lamps and stuff
yeah we we sell like commercial
industrial La lights something so not
relevant to what I do but you could use
the lights for your like equ equally
Lighting on my set is always on point oh
that makes sense you know but that's it
it was no like I want to do this because
I want to change the world right it was
I want to do this because because I want
to be a model for what I want my
daughter to do which is not accept the
narrative as it's written to question
everything to think for yourself and
that's why I do what I do because you
know you can't you can tell a kid a
million times this is how you should
live your life mhm right you can tell
them this is the right way to do it but
it's not the same as doing it yourself
because kids model their parents they're
watching you they're always watching and
doing what you do they're mimicking
constantly so I just wanted do what I
wanted my daughter to do which is
question everything and that's literally
why I do what I do that's it but don't
you think you're setting yourself up for
a lot of Disobedience cuz she's going to
be like I'mma question my daddy you're
conspiracy I am not going to accept that
narrative that you're
G Dad you say do homework but that's a
conspiracy and if she comes up to those
decisions on her own and she makes that
decision because she has reason to
believe it I'm all for it wow right
that's cool if she came up and
analytically thought about a situation
and said that I don't want to go to
college because these are the things I
feel like I can do different great
amazing I'm glad if someone tells her
you have to do something and she does it
because other people told her that's
what to do then I'm against that that's
too much reason for Asian family you
totally broke the chain so hard was it
like growing up did you have like hard
poor Asian parents like straight
immigrant like whatever they say is Law
and you can't like debate yeah my
parents and especially mom is like fully
the indoctrinated elitist type Mom I
love you but but that's how they are
like super educated and education is the
most important and but they also were I
think all Asians deep down in one way
shape and form especially if you if
you're here in the United States you
have a little bit of this
anti-establishment
blood in your DNA because if you didn't
you wouldn't be here yeah you'd be back
over there you're a little Pioneer at
some point in your history of your being
here in this country somebody said damn
the man damn the system something's not
right about where we are let's go to
America for opportunity pck this [__]
[__] the little bit of
anti-establishment pck the emperor and
somehow we got here and all of a sudden
the Asians are like yeah the
establishment they're they got our
they're looking out for our best behalf
it's like really you didn't believe that
home you know but now that's true like
that doesn't make sense so crazy it's
always interesting to me when you see
like the first generation immigrants
they're more like rebellious or they're
more like anti- big government or they
came from communist countries but then
their kids become hella like I don't
know how to explain it it's almost like
they just believe everything that's been
told to them by the institutions from
school to politics to everything and I
don't know how it turns out that way cuz
our propaganda is sick maybe that's what
it is America's good marketing very
believable you know what I notic maybe
it's a class thing because I've noticed
it more in middle class and upper Asians
like broke ghetto Asians are all
anti-establishment right cuz they're
just like don't trust anybody I don't
trust the police they're like
Hillbillies and [__] but then I see
compliance happening from a lot of uh
well to-do Asians and I think it's
because the system works for them so if
you live in a community that's already
safe that's doing well then for them
it's like why do you need a gun I never
needed a gun for my whole entire life
and it's like yeah cuz you live in a
gated community where your security
guards have guns but you never need one
you know it's it's it's it's almost like
they live in a world where it all works
that therefore everyone should follow
that same system and probably the
socioeconomic like system also works in
their favor or they're playing it well
you know yeah yeah I think it's this
desire for social acceptance so if you
comply then they accept you and it's
easier to live your life right so
therefore you comply because your life
is good and then all of a sudden you
want to indoctrinate the people around
you because again life is good once
you're drinking the Kool-Aid once you're
part of the establish and part of the
machine it's not easy to because there's
this idea especially for Asians when
they get into that upper echelon of kind
of the corporate World y they always
kind of feel like they don't belong y
but if they comply with The Narrative of
what they're told then they're accepted
a little bit more and they're scared to
kind of push back because I feel like a
lot of people even in that Echelon of
society don't agree with what's going on
but they don't want to speak out because
they don't want to lose their place in
in the world because at the end of the
day they're trying to make lives better
for their families also and if they step
out on line it could potentially ruin
the futures for their future Generations
today's video is brought to you by
rocket money check this out guys these
days with set it and forget it
subscription style things we have so
many things out there from entertainment
to just straight up bill payment a lot
of money being spent gets forgotten
rocket money is here to help everybody
and for me specifically I'm one of those
people that need that I need an
assistant that just goes through
everything every single month and goes
ha you spent too much here you're doing
this there but I don't have that so
thanks to Rocket money I was able to
identify a phone bill that I kept paying
for that I shouldn't be paying for
anymore because I thought I canceled it
but I didn't cancel it so I've been
paying it for the last five months oh no
and thanks to Rocket money they alerted
me and then I was like wait what's that
doing there and I was able to go EX
excuse me but I didn't even use this for
the last 5 months and I'm supposed to be
off the network and they said you didn't
ccel one I'm like yes I did and then
they go okay well we'll cancel it so
what I like about rocket money is I was
playing around with this app and I'm
like man this would be so helpful in
this day and age and I call it the three
S's and Rocky you should pay me extra
for this okay one subscriptions helps
you with that maybe you got all these
film TV show things that you're
subscribed to you don't even watch any
more it could be hundreds of dollars
going down the drain helps you manage
your subscriptions the other one is
spending you could set spending budgets
so for example you could be like I'm
going have my coffee budget be like 20
bucks a week 30 bucks a week and if you
go over it'll alert you be like hey stop
spending so that's super cool because a
lot of times you know just out having
fun living your life it you don't check
your your your checkbook every single
day the way that we our parents did
because we have so many transactions now
so keep track of your spending and the
last one I think is the most important
is the savings you know like how how am
I able to save money at the end of the
month when you use it all up but what
you can do you can set how much you want
to save either every day or right when a
check comes in put 10 bucks away put a
100 bucks away so you can really get a
hold of your finances like a business
like Top Line bottom line and then get
all your spending in check it's like
your personal Chief finance officer
rocket money is a personal finance app
that find
and cancels your unwanted subscriptions
monitors your spending and helps you
lower your bills rocket money has over 5
million users and has helped save its
members an average of
$720 a year with over $500
million in cancelled subscriptions so
stop wasting money on things you don't
use cancel your unwanted subscriptions
by going to Rocket money.com offthe
record that's rocket money.com sloff
theeere rocket money.com sloff theeere
so they're almost forced to comply it's
a really shitty place to be in because
they have to agree with things that they
don't agree with yeah mhm does your wife
feel the same or have the same views as
you or she's just like shut the [__]
up cuz I feel like you know like I feel
like everyone in here is pretty
intelligent and we probably have like
some intelligent things to say and
people in the world are are receptive
but I feel like when it comes to the
wife's angle it's like here they go
again well she doesn't listen to
me on my videos because she's like I got
to listen to you at home all day why do
I have to watch you on video I would
rather I already know what you're going
to say I already know the content
exactly exactly but I think she
understands what's going on in the world
she was not a political or politically
motivated person ever in the past uh but
I think over the last few years like a
lot of people they kind of see like hey
that that doesn't make sense you know
when they say um you know magga country
is really racist she hears that all the
time but we live in like a really
conservative area of the country and
she's like nobody's racist to us at all
ever yeah so it's like weird to her to
hear that I mean I think that's a part
of the propaganda machine like growing
up here in California going to the
schools here you hear it you've probably
never met a white person but you hear
like people from Texas are a bunch of
like backwards rednecks that are racist
or people from Georgia are all KKK or
whatever and you actually go to the
South and you're like yo the white
people here are so much nicer than the
white people in California and I'm like
what the [__] I've been told all this
stuff about you know they're even worse
and I'm like really I mean it's
anecdotal but that's what I I that
southern hospitality thing it's so true
they're so kind they're like way nicer I
don't know I think New Yorkers and
Californians are even way more mean but
yeah I I've lived in Georgia for 12
years now yeah I don't think I've ever
had a racist experience once dang in In
Living in Georgia if anything people
have been amazing really friendly so
accepting and uh so supportive of what I
do especially in the last 6 months the
only time I've ever experienced racism
in my life is if I'm in like LA or New
York so the places that tell everyone
let's go baby baby racist for Life
racist for baby keep it racist the
places that tell you that the world is
racist are the only places that you
experienced the racism which I think is
so odd I mean La
baby get your Ching CHS out of here I
mean like it's also like you just never
know cuz racism does exist everywhere
bullying exists everywhere so like you
don't know maybe someone had an
experience and then they're just they're
just telling you what they felt I I
think like when I was growing up a lot
of the teachers came from like the Civil
Rights Movement so they had a lot of
like pain and suffering from that era
and they were teaching us what happened
to them and I I have relatives and
people who grew up you know as kids
during World War II or whatever and then
they talk about the interment C they
talk about how they were treated so like
all that stuff is like I think passed
down and maybe it's not even true for
Our Generation and we haven't fir hand
experienced any of this stuff but then
like you're paranoid like oh there's a
[__] racist down the street I know it
you know like I mean there's hella
experiences like that where it's it's so
difficult to say that it it does or it
doesn't exist cuz there's 300 million
people in America and you can't really
make a blanket statement like yeah
there's absolutely no racism in
California or like we're the better ones
and they're not you know see I'm a free
speech Absolut abst meaning racism
actually doesn't bother me at all that's
TI meaning be because the reality is is
that there is a ISM for everything in
life yeah right if you're a if you like
one football team and you have a rival
football team you hate them just as much
as you may hate someone of a different
color right like there are so many ways
to divide people and the market will
decide so if you have if you're if you
have a restaurant in the hood and you're
like we don't cater to black people
people the market around would be like
all right like that's pretty [__] up
we're going to put reviews to say these
guys are racist and they will cancel you
and your business will go out of
business yeah they won't support you
with they won't support you it's the
market will decide it is not the
government's place to show up with the
government gun and tell you what you can
and cannot say I think the federal
government has no say in that matter
because the country itself is so diverse
already we can self-govern ourselves we
don't need the government going to show
up and tell you how to live your life or
or what you can and cannot say and I
think that's the biggest part and
sometimes if you have free speech it
means you have to hear things that you
hate yeah because if you don't hear hate
speech it means Free Speech actually
isn't working mhm so I'm I'm okay with
it like I don't agree with it I may
think you're a shitty person right cuz
the market will decide if you say
something hateful people don't like you
yeah then something's going to happen
right have faith in the people right MH
yeah and on the flip side too with too
much government control I mean when
racism they say like institutional
racism or by law there was racist laws
right all those things it didn't pan out
like people fought against it now we
don't have that you know and a lot of uh
racist uh I guess you know legislation
and law that was that was out there they
no longer exist so I think too much
government control over the people is
dangerous it can be extremely dangerous
yeah so you you mentioned that the last
6 months have just been a Snowball
Effect roller coaster and and everything
like that like where are you now so to
speak with like what you're doing with
where the content's gone with maybe uh
where you might be wanting it to go Etc
did you sell the lighting company yeah
no um I actually don't make money from
what I do so I don't run ads or very
little ads um I don't take sponsors I
don't do paid content which I get a lot
of requests for which is crazy we'll go
into that story later you don't want to
promote like
meundies athletic greens or something
yeah I I don't do any of that I just
kind of talk right right no athletic
greens he doesn't want to be [__]
influenced like we don't need that sh
coffee meets
bagel bagel coffee meets bagel has never
never reached out so maybe we'll do
that you know uh but I don't do any of
that so I don't know what I'm doing I
don't I I've never known what I was
doing since I started you know what I
mean it was just kind of you take one
day as it comes and um somehow I was
able to connect with some of the largest
people in the space which is just wild
and so so give us some of those details
like as a snowball grew like what was
like well I can't believe I'm talking to
this person I can't believe I'm talking
to I can't believe I'm going here or
recognized here so the first kind of big
kind of interview I guess I did was in
June which came out of nowhere um I had
opportunity to be on war room with Steve
bennon so Steve benn's war room is kind
of on the right one of the biggest
podcast and shows out there and they
reached out and their CFO CEO is
actually the korean-american girl which
most people don't know like oh they're
so racist but number two in the entire
steeve B organization is Korean so like
there goes that theory uh but I got to
do his show and then that kind of gave
me my first little bump and then somehow
over time
I made a couple like Pro and Andrew Tate
posts and Andrew Tate reached out and
now we're connected I'm actually
probably going to go to Romania in
February that's cool Cobra Tate you're
telling me do you need a
camera which you know like he's a
polarizing guy but I judge people by the
way they've impacted my life not what
they've done in their lives right I
think that's a good way I just made fun
of him cuz I had no idea who he was yeah
I retract all my statements about people
don't know and you don't know what you
don't know right but for me I think he
just plays a character yeah after I W I
got so hooked on his stuff I love I his
stuff is H I think he he exaggerates a
point he's almost like Borat he
exaggerates a point to make the point
yeah I mean I I got fooled that's why I
thought he was stupid and I realized I
was the dumb one to think that was real
yeah I like when he yells at me and it
get off my ass I like that yeah kind
like oh [__] maybe I should I should
he's way richer than me I should yeah I
mean I think it's effective and I think
the reason that you know they canc him
and they've been trying to cancel him is
because he has the largest inet army in
the world by far no one has more
influence on the internet amongst men
and men that understand how the internet
works than he does wow so if he doesn't
comply you got to get rid of him I
really think that's why because he can
move the
needle pretty much yeah he has an army
of a million plus men that understand
how the internet works wow it's a risk I
really think that's why they went after
him they trying to discredit him
right he needs to come out with the nft
then has a good email list you should
that's the best way to get back
fantastic actually makes I saw a video
where he's yelling at me to sign up for
the email list and I was like all right
sign up for sign me up my email all
right I'll do it then yeah so that was a
huge one and then um and then I got
opportunity to connect with Tucker
Carlson which is
like and for me how did you get him on
your podcast it it just happened man wow
what I got to say his light your
lighting is good but his [__] camera
setup he look [__] like he's in a
barn back on TV dude yeah bro yeah his
his setup and his team is like 10 people
wow which is crazy you think that he
would have like this 100 Man team and I
got to speak to some of the people that
work for him in the background and they
are 100% Believers in his mission which
is like amazing I was talking to them
and they're like when we're at lunch or
dinner and when Tucker is not around
what they say amongst themselves is we
really feel like we're doing God work
wow and the fact that they're so bought
in into what they're doing and what
they're really doing is trying to just
spread truth about what's going on in
the world like I'm you know that's so
amazing to me and they just found me I I
never reached out to them they found me
that's cool that's tight and one of
Tucker's friends who like he trust was
like hey you got to check out this guy's
stuff and he started watching me and and
then one day I saw like one of his team
follow me and I I did what anyone else
would do hi Lexi like I'm a fan like how
are you like I'm here appreciate you
guys and she messaged me back right away
she's like well good news for you Tucker
is actually the one that told me to
start following you and ever since then
we've been in touch and when he
announced his Network I was like Hey
like what are the chances like I can
meet with him not even like can he be on
my show not can I be on his show like I
just want to meet him and I want to ask
him questions because I've had such
quick growth in 6 months I feel like
there's so much I need to learn like I
want to know what's going on and she was
like even better like I'm sure he'd be
willing to do your show and that's how
it happened wow just like wow wow that's
really cool I wonder why you're getting
so much like love and and and attention
from like the right and nothing are you
getting anything from the in independent
or or the left or anything no cuz when I
see your content I never thought of it
as a rightwing
I always saw it as like
anti-establishment I saw it as you know
someone who's just like wait a minute
the media might not be telling you
everything they might have a biased
opinion they might be funded by someone
just look at the sources and for me
that's not a right-wing leftwing thing
it's more like check your sources yeah I
I think the I think through that process
just like you said I think it's pretty
clear the top of the left is part of the
establishment that controls the media
and part of the far right that is maybe
we we like to call the Rhinos they're
just as in bed with establishment media
they don't like me they don't like
someone that's questioning what their
official narrative what their official
talking points are right it's the people
that want to break away from that that
kind of want to be freethinking that
want to question their narrative those
are the people that have been really
embracing me uh so it's not just only
the left that doesn't support me it's
part of the right also that really hate
what I do it's it's not like just one
side right yeah I first came across your
content cuz my wife Gio followed you and
then like you know we the same you
yelling at the TV but it's me and Gio
yelling at each other like what the [__]
they're talking about this again we
always felt like is there like anyone
else that doesn't think like this so we
would always have like these
conversations you hey check this guy out
that's when I first came across your
content I'm like yes another Asian
person that isn't like [__] drunk
with this crazy like it's crazy that
everyone has the same thoughts cuz it's
not even like that in a classroom yeah
you know hey we have homework tomorrow
ah [__] you I love homework oh man you
know there's like homework
theast it's [__] in in the state or
like in the nation it's like homework
andone say yeah put up my [__]
ass I'm like what the [__] since when
dude I've never heard it like that but
now I understand that's how I feel dude
since when did we like shoving homework
up our ass weird yeah I don't expect
anyone to agree with everything I say I
don't think it's impossible I think
that's weird actually to agree with
everything I think if anything even
identical twins fight yeah
I if you agree with everything someone
says it just means you're living in an
echo chamber right you should always
question what you're what you hear and
you know if anything tell me I'm wrong I
love it when you tell me I'm wrong but
as long as you believe I'm wrong because
you believe I'm wrong because you've
done your own research and Prov me wrong
and I've changed my opinion on things
all the time because maybe what I
researched wasn't as comprehensive that
I should be maybe you provided a
different perspective than what I had
like that's how people should be that's
how people really are in real life and
this idea that you pick a side and you
pick a stance on a point and that's your
point for the rest of your life it's so
[__] weird it is weird you know like
that's your Hill to die on why yeah I
have no it's like a weird religion to me
like a cult where I've been seeing like
people commenting on like popular Asian
pages and then they're like if you vote
right then you're voting for anti-
Asians mm and I'm all like what are you
talking about like it's not a racial was
his comment mhm stop trolling everyone
every liked it too everyone like the
satire he's actually the troll of the
that was
me